the corruption of our system
is so severe
that at the point your system is lying
to you i mean a lot of my friends got
caught by the lies because they were
used to public health lying to them
public health lies
because that's part of its job right it
oversimplifies things in order to get
you to do the right thing
and so the fact that it was lying to
noble lie a noble lie right they assumed
that's why they were being lied to
now heather and i looked at this and
thought
wait a minute
those lies
don't look like noble lies
they look like corrupt lies
and those corrupt lies
resulted in who knows how many tens of
billions of dollars being made by
particular folks
and those folks
play a game where they use government
to
coerce
use of their products
right it's a very unusual
market where
you know it's not supply and demand it's
supply and demand date
and
that
means
that there's a reason to be
hyper-vigilant
about the danger that what you're being
told isn't actually in your medical
interest
[Music]
you